un tout autre visage de la
seine-saint-denis maintenant un visage
musicale avec le festival banlieues
bleues depuis 15 ans le département
accueille les meilleurs artistes de jazz
au programme 36 spectacles dont une
moitié de création et d'inédits ce soir
le pianiste michel petrucciani jouera à
noisy-le-grand avec ses cinq musiciens
il sera en direct avec nous dans
quelques secondes juste après cet
extrait d'une dernière répétition cet
après-midi regarder
à
et
oh
alors retrouvons maintenant en direct à
noisy-le-grand michel petrucciani
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est très rare de vous voir en france
vous vivez on sait aux états unis
pourquoi deux niveaux aussi peu de
spectacles en france donne pas mal on
est en tournée on fait dix sept concerts
en france là ce mois ci et le mois
prochain
non quand il fait chaud en france deux
festivals d'été
non non non faut pas dire ça alors cette
fois vous êtes vous jouez dans une
banlieue est ce que c'est un choix de
votre part alors vous êtes l'un des très
très grand pianiste du jazz je crois
qu'il faut aller partout je pense qu'il
faut pas il faut pas être sectaire il
faut le jouer partout quand on me
demande de venir dont vient très
volontiers quoi vous pensez que la
musique et surtout le jazz peut occuper
une place importante dans ces quartiers
difficiles
je pense que l'art en général la musique
oui occupe une place importante
je pense que si on arrive à faire
oublier un petit peu les problèmes ne
serait ce que dix minutes de quelqu'un
c'est karl déjà pas mal alors là votre
spectacle aura lieu tout à l'heure
comment se prépare un spectacle de jazz
et ce qu'il faut une grande
concentration au contraire une certaine
détente pour pouvoir improviser
il faut une grande concentration on est
aux touristes que nous parce que vous
allez on arrive là
j'arrive de paris vous êtes là et on va
commencer dans pas une petite heure donc
prenez un peu habitué à tout enfant il
faudra arriver au moins à se calmer mais
être seule une dizaine de minutes
alors ce soir vous jouez avec cinq
musiciens pourquoi le choix de cette de
cette formation parce que d'abord c'est
bon c'est mon dernier disque s'appelle
ghost world qui est sorti chez chez
dreyfus et j'ai pris au moins deux
grands musiciens style gad à la batterie
antoni jackson à la basse stefano di
battista au saxophone fireball trop à la
trompette et denis leloup au trombone
alors michel petrucciani on sait que
vous êtes on vous considère comme le
pianiste le plus doué de votre
génération dit que vous allez devenir
une légende vivante du jazz
est-ce que c'est pas difficile à assumer
tout ça enfin voir j'essaie de rester
vivant déjà les gens ne cède pas et puis
de louer vous savez quand on travaille
autant que moi je crois que c'est c'est
normal de savoir un peu jouer quoi
michel petrucciani merci et vous êtes
donc je rappelle vous êtes en concert ce
soir à noisy-le-grand
[Musique]